you say it unless I don't think we're
going to get the
the
actual event for Starfield next month
because at that point
maybe it's just a time restraint or
anything like that but it's just like
maybe we'll get like the beginning of
March okay
I I don't know because like it's just
it's just weird it's like you heard the
same thing right Gene
it's just this is your biggest game this
year this is the game everyone's asking
for this is the game that people
realistically expected at the Video Game
Awards and this is the only game you're
not shown like and like cool I get it
it's a big game you want to give it
enough time to really unwind unwrap
Starfield but you could easily do that
and still have star throughout this
event I'm not giving them that excuse
you